well the mayor of an illinois town is
demanding an apology from the state's
governor after being labeled xenophobic
for sounding the alarm about dozens of
migrants sent to his community from the
city of chicago those migrants arriving
without background checks or health
screenings and on very little notice
craig johnson is the mayor of elk grove
village and joins us right now mayor
good morning to you
good morning steve thank you for having
me it's great to have you so on
september the 9th you got a call from
the governor's office and said hey we're
gonna we're bringing a bus full of
migrants to your place and you said wait
what and you asked them some questions
and they didn't have any answers did
they
well what happened was we got word that
some migrants are coming we asked how
many we don't know where they going we
don't know what time they're going to
get here we don't know and more
importantly we ask what kind of safety
backgrounds have they had done and what
kind of health backgrounds they've had
done because that's important for our
community i mean i'm elected to serve
and protect the health and safety and
welfare of our village and i needed to
do that right and i understand you said
well if they haven't been screened for
uh their health and they have not
undergone a background check you're not
going to dump them off here
well we told them until we got answers
to those questions we couldn't let them
come into elko village you're exactly
right okay so they got back to you hours
later and they said oh you know what
they've all had health uh background
checks and they've had uh security
checks and they're okay
did you believe that
uh steve i i do um i got it from the um
director of homeland security for the
mexican border region and he assured me
that there were checks for covet monkey
parks and other health issues and they
did do a biometric screening for the
background so i want to have faith in
our federal government so once we heard
that and we said okay they're allowed in
steve one thing i want to make sure i
put out these are human beings
absolutely so we want to treat them with
dignity and respect but we want to make
sure that they're safe for our community
sure and be involved here so that's what
we checked first and once that was
accomplished
we did you know we're fine having now in
our community
so our big problem steve steve our big
problem is we weren't given any answers
and we're still not getting answers and
what really bothered me was the governor
he has pretty much labeled suburban
mayors xenophobic and to me that's wrong
nothing could be worse than saying that
about local communities my community has
reached out to help these folks give
stuff donate things and we're trying to
find them jobs elk grove's home to the
biggest business park in north america
we've got jobs we'll hook them up to
jobs we're matching remember they are
technically legal here the president
united states says they're legal so
we're treating them as legal people but
we want to give them jobs give them to
work and be able to take care of
themselves and pay taxes to everybody
great mayor real quick so you're angry
at the governor does he owe you an
apology
oh yes we asked for the governor to
apologize to elk grove village my
community and my residents we're not
xenophobic we're complete opposite we're
welcoming and we want to continue to
welcome people and like i said these
migrants are humans and treat them with
respect and dignity they deserve and
we'll give them jobs we'll help take
care of them but don't call us ever
again xenophobic listen if he calls you
uh let us know because we want to hear
what he said we also heard that
apparently chicago said yeah the reason
we have to ship them there is because
we've got a marathon
in about a month which is just nuts
mayor thank you you're right thank you
so much craig johnson uh for joining us
uh
we're glad that we could finally get to
the bottom of what happened but it's
very troubling thank you sir
and steve real quick thank you
congratulations on your new cookbook and
if you could do me a favor i could use a
copy brian's book is getting lonely
behind me there okay
i'll do the best i can thank you very
much mayor thank you sir thank you have
a good day
look at that a book tease right in the
middle of that segment on the border
thank you very much by the way we did
reach out to the governor's office have
not heard back probably won't hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now